i have just accepted her majesty the
queen's
kind invitation to form a new government
let me pay tribute to my predecessor
boris johnson delivered brexit
the covert vaccine and stood up to
russian aggression
history will see him
as a hugely consequential prime minister
i'm honored to take on this
responsibility at a vital time for our
country
what makes the united kingdom great
is our fundamental belief
in freedom in enterprise and in fair
play
our people have shown grit courage and
determination time and time again
we now face severe global headwinds
caused by russia's appalling war in
ukraine
and the aftermath of covet
now is the time to tackle the issues
that are holding britain back
we need to build roads homes and
broadband faster
we need more investment and great jobs
in every town and city across our
country
we need to reduce the burden on families
and help people get on in life
i know that we have what it takes to
tackle those challenges
of course it won't be easy
but we can do it
we will transform britain into an
aspiration nation
with high-paying jobs
safe streets and where everyone
everywhere has the opportunities they
deserve
i will take action this day
and action every day
to make it happen
united with our allies we will stand up
for freedom and democracy around the
world
recognizing that we can't have security
at home
without having security abroad
as prime minister i will pursue three
early priorities
firstly i will get britain working again
i have a bold plan to grow the economy
through tax cuts and reform
i will cut taxes to reward hard work
and boost business-led growth and
investment
i will drive reform in my mission to get
the united kingdom working building and
growing
we'll get spades in the ground to make
sure people are not facing unaffordable
energy bills and we will also make sure
that we are building hospitals schools
roads are broadband
secondly i will deal hands-on with the
energy crisis caused by putin's war
i will take action this week to deal
with energy bills and to secure our
future energy supply
thirdly i will make sure that people can
get doctors appointments and the nhs
services they need
we will put our health service on a firm
footing
by delivering on the economy
on energy and on the nhs
we will put our nation on the path to
long-term success
we shouldn't be daunted by the
challenges we face
as strong as the storm may be
i know that the british people are
stronger
our country was built by people who get
things done
we have huge reserves of talent of
energy and determination
i am confident that together we can ride
out the storm
we can rebuild our economy
and we can become the modern brilliant
britain that i know we can be
this is our vital mission to ensure
opportunity and prosperity for all
people and future generations
i am determined to deliver
thank you
liz truss
having just taken over from boris
johnson posing outside the famous black
door
with her husband
before entering
to start work
as she said
action this day
are you daunted by the task prime
minister do you have a plan
[Applause]